it's been a long and trying season
hasn't it what was supposed to be a very
loaded season that should have featured
a lot of blockbusters and sequels has
become barren for a lack of a better
term in large part due to the pandemic
we've been left with a season that is a
shell of its former self long runners
and surprising hits that were on pace to
do really well like millionaire
detective have been cut short meanwhile
railgun t apparently turned into a
monthly anime as it tried jizan and
struggles to finish its first
however in line with trying to think
positive I think that the seasons not
all that bad tower of gods entertaining
as hell ascendance of a bookworm is on
pace to wrap-up
Kaguya sama survived the sequel purge
and is still at the top of its game and
globe Nair has quickly become one of the
most enjoyed shows of the season
now thick into the admittedly drained
season we've got only one way to look
forward into the summer season a season
that at the time of writing offers a
glimmer of hope and a lot of excitement
unfortunately I won't be surprised to
see some of the following shows suffer
delays yes even the ones that were
scheduled for this season could still
not see the light of day next season
should things go bad pray for Subaru
guys
sucio games brings us our first entry to
the list the action sci-fi anime aqua
dharma drive featuring an alternative
history where a Great War divided Japan
into two regions our Kodama drive takes
place in Kansai being made a vassal
state Kansai has since fallen in terms
of law and politics and the police are
slowly losing the region to criminals
called aku Dharma we take a look at the
ark Adama and how they cope with this
dystopian society it's easy to see why
the designs in the art star would look
familiar
featuring the people who bought as
dangan ronpa I think we can be free to
have some high expectations for this one
it's an original anime that will likely
be full of surprises and seeing as how
the team are already experienced in
dealing with the moral greys that will
likely be featured here let's say that
this show could be a great addition to
this strong season originally announced
a year ago decadence to finally go it's
release date in sight and it's set to
come out this summer season along with
aqua gamma drive decadence is one of the
three anime originals that have been
getting a whole lot of hype this coming
season so far it looks like an anime
take on mortal engines with its
steampunk aesthetics nifty character
designs an absolutely gorgeous art I'm
not in the slightest surprised to see so
many people excited for decadence from
what we can see with the trailers the
art and animation for the series looks
nothing short of fantastic with the
brilliant minds that brought us cult
classic you Joe Sankey as well as death
parade and mob psychos director at the
helm I'm sure that this is a show that a
lot of you guys could really enjoy for
now all we can do is wait and see
knowing those people taking charge
though I'm pretty positive that the show
won't disappoint next in line is the
second season of fire force through all
the troubles and the unfortunate
real-life circumstances that coincided
with his first season fire force managed
to carve out a niche among Shonen fans
thanks to its engaging narrative
memorable and memorable characters and
core powers fire force left fans wanting
more when it first stopped shinra and
the squad are set to return after the
amazing battles in the first part of
fire force and I wouldn't want to miss
out on what's to come for the team it
may not have been as big as other hits
shown in contemporaries like Demon
Slayer or my hero academia but fire
force is a nice Shonen anime
with some really great animation and
fights that you shouldn't miss out on
while we wait for the second part this
July why not take this chance to watch
the first part and do some catching up
my
at number 7 we have the return of
time-travel anime in the form of gb8
perhaps in a twist especially relevant
to current times GBA features a future
Tokyo ravaged by a virus the virus named
GBA has been spending some time turning
people into monsters in a scene that
could be reminiscent of some zombie
movies facing them our time-traveling
samurai and ninja did you see something
like that coming I don't think so the
last thing on my mind is having a series
that features time-traveling samurai and
ninja taking on a viral scourge to save
the world
maybe they'll soon come save us all from
a similar health crisis after all what
do you think jokes aside this anime is
just oozing with stylish Flair from what
I've seen a bit the art looks really
cool and as early as now I'm predicting
this to be the sleeper hit of the season
in terms of production and animation
come join the battle this July
[Music]
confidence moans convinced the miracle
in sixth place is great Pretender just
when you thought you've seen it all
comes this new anime about con games yep
you heard that right
the anime about con games which was
first unveiled sometime last year is
about to hit our screens this July great
pretend that starts to con men traveling
all over the world they say that the
only life worth living is one full of
thrills and these two sure have them
danger lurks in every corner though and
these two are living a life full of
risks and all the other twists and turns
a con man would have overall the anime
looks pretty promising with his
production values and without even
seeing it I think the show is gonna
feature some nifty play on morality
along with the - of comedic elements
great pretenders looking to be a good
change of pace from what we're used to
seeing in anime and I'm sure as hell
excited to watch it on opening night
now this one hurt personally mere weeks
before it was scheduled to air the grand
finale to Sao Zanna sensation arc was
delayed to July thanks to you know what
apparently there was a bottleneck in
terms of voice acting and thanks to a
number of other internal issues we're
all gonna have to wait at least a couple
of months to see our favorite Sao
characters graced the screen once again
with a confrontation of epic proportions
in the return of fan favorites from all
the previous arcs of Sao looming war of
underworld second part is sure to be a
treat to anyone who's stuck by the
series through the decade with the
series fake point uncertain for now I
among the numerous Sao fans worldwide
hope that the team pulls through this
time and gives us the proper closure for
what's been one of the more engaging
arcs in the series history hope we get
to see all end this summer coming in at
number 4 we have Higurashi 2020 what's
with all these franchise revivals in the
past years if it's not an ancient manga
being remade you have old franchises
being revived with sequels or
supplementary material I mean don't get
me wrong that's not a bad thing by any
means and I think among the ones that
received the revival treatment Higurashi
is certainly one of the more deserving
series Higurashi back in its heyday was
one of the premiere horror thriller
anime series coupling twists mysteries
and a lot of graphic violence
it made its mark in the visual novel and
anime community now I'm not sure if a
lot of people were holding out for an
anime continuation back then but if the
reception to this plan 2020 continuation
is anything to go by Higurashi looks
like it's primed to come back with a
vengeance let's see how all this plays
out this July I'm sure that a lot of
longtime fans are ready to get back on
the ride that's your Tucson's Conda
[Music]
third on the list is god of high school
korean titles sure wanted to join in on
the fun in the whole anime thing
goodnight tower of god as far as western
reception goes is looking to be a
consistent success story now with that
in mind we have our next Korean
contender in line in god of high school
starring jin mori a cocky and headstrong
korean martial artist god of high school
tells our protagonist trip into the
world of martial
thanks to a rude awakening courtesy of a
blonde man his journey to become a
legend in the tournament called the God
of high school begins a battle shown in
prime to make its mark on the anime
community the god of High School is a
series that you ought to look out for
the last of the officially delayed
series that we should be expecting in
the coming season rezero still maintains
a lot of momentum going forward we've
talked about it multiple times before
but the hype is still that strong to
have this to be the most second
anticipated summer 2020 show overall
season one recently got a director's cut
that ended the series in one massive
cliffhanger for now I'd suggest watching
the director's cut of the first season
as well as the two OVA s one of the OVA
in particular makes great supplementary
material as it's a movie length prologue
that details parts of Amelia's backstory
let's just hope that things clear out so
we can finally see the continuation to
one of the greatest a Sakai series in
the modern era
[Music]
well they sure made us wait for this on
didn't they they couldn't have picked a
worse time to end a run with one of the
biggest cliff hangers that's at the same
time poetic in delivery and execution
they really just left us hanging in the
midst of an epic story and in my opinion
one of the best arcs in the series as a
whole you bet that thousands of fans
would be tuned in to see how the story
continues with this next core of high Q
a lot more challenges await our gritty
karasuno team it's a long treacherous
climb up the mountain but we'll finally
see if our boys have what it takes to
overcome everything and make their mark
in history forget the death flags for
caras who knows hopes they're putting it
all on the line this time and there's no
turning back
July can't come soon enough so the
summer season looks good doesn't it be a
shame if something happened to it jokes
aside I really hope that we can get a
good season this time round as for you I
hope you stay safe stay healthy and stay
strong it's only a matter of time the
anime will surely come back stronger
than ever as always don't hesitate to
leave a like and subscribe if you
enjoyed watching this video be the first
in line for the next video because I'll
keep delivering even through these
trying times video tube goodness takes
no breaks
[Music]
[Music]